Everyone's pretty clear that there are dog people and there are cat people.
Yes, there are people that are both,...
...but we're looking simplicity here so let's move on.
And according to research from Carroll University,...
...cat people are the smarter of those two groups.
The researchers surveyed 600 students...
...and aside from asking them questions about their personality,...
...they also asked how they felt about dogs and cats.
For the record, 60% are dog people, 11% are cat people.
The rest liked either both or neither.
Dog people valued the companionship from their pet while cat owners liked the affection.
But when paired with the personality traits, these results got really interesting.
Cat lovers scored higher on intelligence tests than dog lovers.
They also tended to be introverted, nonconformist, open-minded, sensitive thinkers.
Conversely, dog lovers were more energetic, outgoing, extroverted and meticulous.